hello everyone and welcome to the
GameSpot III 2017 co-op stage I am
Lawrence and we are funhouse we will be
your host for the next 90 minutes as we
guide you through a bunch of very
intelligent discussion about maybe
alternative bedroom practices no no no
we got that we're not gonna do that
instead we're going to just talk about
III s past and present and perhaps
future as I said before I'm Lawrence I'm
joined by Bruce lubbers hello and we got
James on the couch hello
Annelise how are you Lisa hello so I
think yes Wow Wow her name is great
right item one thank you very much yeah
I like this this is an easy audience
better be as quiet as this whole thing
get I don't want to fall you mom I've
seen tensity oh it is essentially like a
rock concert it's okay to scream
lighters may not be oh well lighter
plays and run Fraser phones now
I saw strange man roving around the
audience is there a strange man bags
everyone behind the camera Oh sir yes
there he is security yeah well hopefully
you won't bother anybody unfortunately
there are only four chairs up here yet
if it cuts somewhere but we have a
variety of exciting activities planned
for you guys plus a chance to win free
stuff and what is e3 without waiting in
lines for a long time to win something
you'll probably never use that's what we
promised you today the tree three
experience to begin with uh I love e3
I've loved III for a very long time how
much do you love III Lawrence a whole
lot I love e3 enough that I made a game
show about e3 and that's what we're
about to play he seems so excited does
it yeah I'm angry
let me through so much that I get mad at
both like I'm your damn hose okay
basically any emotional temperature that
goes above five with me is just anger
anyway so here's the idea
III has been host to a lot of great
things and a lot of not-so-great things
a lot a lot of fertile meme ground if I
were to call it that yeah so what's
going to happen is we will see a stage
demo of a game that debuted e3 some of
them are awesome and memorable some of
them are kind of infamous for whatever
reason so we're going to see that just
to bask in the memory
and then some of you guys will have to
guess what you think the Metacritic
score for that game ended up being and
can't look it up because it's not
multiple platforms and you don't know
which one I chose uh uh and then it's
Price is Right rules the person who
comes closest without going over wins a
prize
and you also must play against one of
them so oh really yes oh no yeah I
dropped that one on the real champions
okay you have to defeat the champions
that's right cuz we all we do is go on
Metacritic so we know which games to
scream about so I'm going to invite two
people up you'll wat will watch a
montage of a stage demo you'll put in
your guesses compete against one of them
if they win they get to pick which one
of you is the winner
so probably good idea to suck up to them
now so applause they're nice
I shot Lawrence Thank You applause Simon
yes a lot of this yes Beca uh let's get
sucking up all right now yeah yeah money
is acceptable so uh let's start inviting
people up I need a stick mic would would
you choose or here I'll do it alright
alright let's see some hands who wants
to only rated feel free to touch it law
writers out there you can touch him
shake his hand you got you me reach for
him go ahead and step on state floated
river alright like oh you picks a guy in
any Achievement Hunter shirt oh I didn't
see that I'm sorry oh you're here just
come on up with me and progress share
that's whatever hahaha stay there so
there actually that works that works
probably doing the CHEO they can see
down there okay
nice to meet you what's your name Connor
Connor and ivory right I can hold your
bag for you blindfold
don't let him hold your bag don't let
him right Oh see what a help oh the bag
troll has it alright cuz we're gonna
show some stuff on this monitor
absolutely I can alright let's look at
the first III clip from times past
coming up right now I hope it's rollin
there the bidding war team has been
developing call of duty 4 modern warfare
throwback feel like back there d3 1992
Ukraine take one out when the others are
looking I hated this mission this
mission was awesome I hated it really
yeah he's driving at the end thank you
so tense though good you guys aren't
looking at your phones or respect that
yeah we were watching he outside though
no shouting numbers if you're looking it
up right now I see if I see that phone
in your hand must swat it out to
American Sign Language either this was
awesome man and sit there with all the
cakes rolling around here that's cool
this is what's cool
Chansey looks up dead you know like
modern warfare who doesn't
I like the I like the thought of like
afterwards you tell one of the soldiers
that you were there and that group
didn't even know
all right sirs time to register your
guesses again closest without going over
what do you think the Metacritic score
call of duty 4 modern warfare
ended up being I'm gonna go away 8.5
okay well Metacritic scores are 0 to 100
so we can 80 80 80 okay
conservative what would you say 88 I've
got an 80 and an 88 both very good
guesses and since this is a Lisa's
favorite game of all time hahaha what do
you think the Metacritic score ended up
being I'm gonna say 90 Wow okay wait
Price is Right rules right without going
live so we got 80 88 and 90 but Elise
can't win anything so doesn't yeah then
she decides who wins if she went so
let's see what did the Metacritic score
for college 84 Modern Warfare end up
being 92 oh that means a loser
noobs yeah oh these are for scoring oh
yeah eight board five on there alright
at least who wins
well show it to the audience first who
is this beautiful prize hey actually
actually this is fun fact they're gonna
be the first person to actually have
this shirt out of a legacy I apologize
um thank you I don't know uh well he got
Satan he gets what 88 right he was
closer yeah are you gonna use any gore
we have the users oh your modesty is so
compelling oh man I know at least cut
this shirt in half yeah you guys sweet
Achievement Hunter shirt so I think I
have to give you a fun house shirt all
right cover it up when we can give
another okay and and and just because
who cares that actually worked out worse
we're all losers
for all the losers alright thank you
guys ah treasured memories huh and free
stuff this is what this is what you
three is all about right these moments
right okay let's move on to round two
who else wants to try to win from free
stuff now that they know that there's
yeah we have some squeak oh cool how
much lag on so much stuff I brought a
James angel shirt oh I brought a troll
shirt Oh lots of shirts
I can't wait to crush all of them and
yeah just uh I guess have a seat what's
your name
Isaac Isaac nice to meet you Isaac
welcome my champion
then thank you thank you for watching
I'm not you're wasting your time here
sorry might be a bit of an OSHA hazard
if we have bolt up there look at that
you should just step right off have a
seat
my leash I had nightmares of somebody
just busting their teeth out so Isaac
Isaac yeah and what is your name
Harrison Harrison Harrison Harrison
sweet name I think you got an edge
already I'm sorry I think Isaac's a
sweet name to look at Isaac's hairdo
it's [ __ ] awesome shirt by the way
and Game Stop TV just like oh yeah like
you're watching or flowers
oh you sees our videos at work I was
like you see us at work are we at
Gamestop all the time that's weird
alright well let's see the next clip
from e3 spaz
oh boy I know hey it happened okay it
wasn't that bad
what the hell it hurt me a noise first
can we go music great yeah
oh my gosh it's just like he's there
look it's not over yet
look at the audience look at all excited
they are out there for it
hey guys I know could even model the
hood all right screw it we're doing
direct looking upload a 30 minute video
oh he's good drew scooter your drummer I
could do that solo is he good uh he's
great it's a draw best drummer in the
world why why is that right yeah he's
good Wow playing rush oh really rolling
it there he also looks really cool doing
it yeah see look at his collar so high
that's what every we came to Valdis - I
love you nintendo a lot all right that
was we music a brilliant a brilliant
introduction for a brilliant concept
Isaac what do you think the Metacritic
were for we music ended up being
probably 45 no I'm out all right again
coaches without going over so it's a
pretty safe bet Harrison what would you
say 67 67 all right 45 67 and the number
one meet we music fan Bruce alright I
just found out about the gaming Coniston
oh yeah I've actually never seen that um
I'm gonna say 72 okay 45 67 72 what was
the score
Oh 4562 262 sir Wow 62 I think so yeah
here sir I need to write these down yeah
Harrison twins good job Eric oh well you
nailed it let's drop Harrison alright
brought more marks than I thought so you
got a lot of stuff I'm gonna give you a
now the bottle game Lizzie is like
basically you play the drums and then
you could do this and conduct a symphony
which by the way is other people playing
music but it's to your time now anyone
now uh and screw it
I've actually only have large shirts
neither of you guys look like you think
there's everybody three over to the rack
and logical performance
we're view so exactly something like her
you LAN or something and they're like
where am I and what am i doing and they
saw the conductor in there oh now I know
yeah I did hear something happens for
for joining have a good show
thanks Harrison thanks Isaac man all
right yeah I'm good I'm good that's
right keep me track of time I prepared a
lot of these was it a sake cause hands
gonna go we and we could do these a lot
all day only been ten minutes right all
day it's only been ten minutes all right
round three okay so with some stuff okay
let me try to let me try to serve some
underserved areas cuz I'm not the bomb
into the aisle here
probably getting out of range he's gone
I love them in Lawrence again I was I
say he's out playing like Maury Odyssey
or something it's gonna get taken it's
gonna look like when uh when there's a
cartoon fight I just clouds
hahaha set off and then his shirts gonna
fly them one more see ya so many hands
you sir
you look good come on look at look at
out disapproved disapproving Adam is ha
ha ha ha ha ha game show at e3 it'll
never work
no thank you I mean he's right it's not
it's not working
Lawrence you're doing a great job worked
so hard are you doing a great job line
thank you I'm totally kidding I have a
crisis of self confidence about this
time in any show we do so it's only
gonna get very emotionally unstable from
here hoster what is your name hi my name
is Blake Blake nice to meet you and you
sir what is your name my name is Lucas
all right Blake and Lucas let's see the
next video from III is past its halo 2
you win
that is Adam look now took two in the
nose then problem I guess they'll be no
gutters contact hello
go go go man this was real i watch this
a lot end up being mostly lies another
story these three though that big gun
you'll need to gone so sure that for
Halo 3 he would have a gun in his helmet
or like the kneecaps
and
Oya swords
[Music]
title car yes it happened a long time
ago
what's your evening leopard that that
looks like what a mobile game would look
like now but the trailer for it would be
live action and have Arnold
Schwarzenegger in it and also the actual
game it'd just be that yeah I mean that
would be pretty cool all right
halo to debut a 2003 the thunderous
applause a fraction of which we just
heard sir what do you think the
Metacritic score ended up being uh I
don't know probably like I I know for
most in fact that halo was generally
positive so I have to say at least like
an 80% say nay T pre halo - okay okay
conservative but not bad all right what
would you say its closest without going
over right that's correct
$1.00 you're gonna bet one right so you
think it would you think he went over it
you think 80 was too high for halo check
I don't also strategy is a little flawed
cuz you aren't the last person to guess
yeah that doesn't work yeah yeah it
doesn't matter just that does not how it
works
actually yeah I'm gonna ask a the
mysterious man in the audience Adam Adam
why would you guess the Metacritic score
of Halo 2 is 100 105 Joe Adam he's a
little 3-way they just say 81 90 yeah oh
my god why 80 why was 190 and I'm
playing the metagame you say not one yes
all the shirts he could ever want ever
out of a swimming in shirts alright
let's see what the Metacritic score for
yellow - and it being 95 which wordly
means 80 has one dollar no it was 80
yeah he's an ID right
he said 95 okay I don't win - nevermind
y'all ready have shirts Adam I meet the
95 right he wants a sure then you yeah
oh yeah yeah wait Adam wants a shirt
giving you the extra large troll shirt
look I won't hit the camera yeah huh oh
wow that's a cool fake then trader it if
you can't see he threw it straight out
of with no
in the sea Adams dropped his hands in
the guy behind him caught it so enjoy a
consolation prize sir uh are either of
you over 21 yes
I mean here is a Sam Adams they don't
they don't have to drink out of
I'm just saying orange you like I would
send the wrong message you get a fine
ass branded steel flask and then I'm
gonna give you a fun house branded
whiskey glass which is pretty face it
just goes to show it doesn't matter what
you come up here and guess don't get up
on me go get her get her prize well he
got one he didn't even try do you have a
pulse
come up on stage thank you guys thank
you thank you again guys now truth be
told I brought exactly the right number
of prizes for only one person to get one
but I think this is going a little
slower than I thought so I'm at liberty
to I brought extra prizes yeah and Bruce
brought I surprises so thank Bruce is a
forethought and my poor planning for
being awash with free stuff all right
round four let's go Oh God more and more
hands every time where haven't I been
yet walking away from you blowing round
right here you right up front please and
what else we got I get hidden sir in the
blue shirt yes hmm I know the Hat that
visor
oh I see dyador hello he's already won a
hat he's gonna possess you don't put
that on I wanted to throw it is that the
W whatever it lands on then you own any
put in the time James go that way off
the st. James off the stage so I'm
pretty sure I read the Q&A that when
mario possesses a human it kills the
human yeah that makes sense
Oh thrown out there keep that in mind
when you're playing it you murder
whatever you throw your hat on or just
kind of lobotomize them or a Napoleon
doctor I'm good what's your name
Rebecca Rebecca thank you for playing
and what is your name sir Mike Mike nice
to meet you Rebecca and Mike thank you
for playing let's see you the next
memory of e3
greatest the greatest trailer of all
time
oh yeah the greatest trick the devil
ever pulled
so I guess Dead Island might be like
third thing is we aim ended up being
pretty close to this
no no oh yeah the smoke was different in
the light worse
watch sucks too ended up pretty close
you in terms of like I'm driving through
the city think Blanc goodness goodness
deep
they're sure gonna point in watchdogs
Reata acts and he cuts someone and he
goes pakia that's good does he do that -
maybe that would have that's why I don't
think they have axes as a weapon I just
got that billiard ball on a on a string
you're gonna deliver a message for me
yeah sure
this might be too violent close your
eyes everybody no no way
act you look at me look at my eyes look
at me look in my eye don't look at that
look at the digital bullet did your boy
the hack for brains right out of their
skull underscore don't forget the
underscore I did not Dornan or not no
one would alright well slightly infamous
game for it's a very very far-reaching
debut infamous is a different game
you're right nevermind I'm allure but
different so what would you expect a
Metacritic score for that game ended up
being probably like 85 85 Oh Stella dick
saw the pic sir what about you I'll go
with 65 oh wow okay
85 65 and top watchdogs expert James yes
are you renting it I'm gonna split the
middle oh yeah I'm gonna split the
middle I'm gonna go 75 okay
write down the Mexi 5 75 85 wait no you
were 85 85 75-65 I used to work in a
restaurant there wasn't time with a
cheeseburger
you had the spaghetti just a plate of a
soak in a bowl let's see what the medic
redick's work for watchdog ended up
being I think it's 85 oh no you were 85
yeah I was 75 yeah he was so many fun
you're 65 year 85 it's a great concept
for Oedipus what are you nice try you're
not putting that hold on give me the Hat
okay uh he won well prizes for no one
give me the prize Lawrence what do you
got for me
yeah that's a Volk or tank top Oh folk
or tank uh there hold on I can't wait to
wear this I think I have a troll shirt
in here somewhere
troll shirt a beanie hold on let me see
what I got
let me see what I got No
Oh where's the James angel shirt
do we not pack any oh god that's my
protein bar that's Bruce's protein bars
I'll touch that there's another monitor
ladies would you use a water bottle oh
well okay there you are oh you got one
here all right thank you guys for
playing hold on you ever gotten anything
yet yeah I gave much I get my tank top
oh so I actually did win this oh no I
gave him something else oh you got the
beanie yeah okay all right right a man
of many hats thank you thanks guys
thanks for coming up all right
round five oh it's eaten up now yeah
you're right I haven't gotten anybody
over here
you guys already up stuff ha you seem
very excited so oh please help yourself
on stage what what sure you are sir have
a seat hello welcome I'm encouraging the
wrong kind of behavior and I know that
now
people are gonna start like slide
tackling me you've ate it all right what
is your name sir Jerry Hernandez very
nice to meet you and you sir Julian
Finley
all right Jerry Julian thank you guys
for joining us on the gamespot III co-op
stage let's see what the next clip for
me threes past is yes Hugo got yes
académica have you all been getting your
sweat on lately the one game that I
wanted to introduce to all of you at e3
this year was not Super Mario Galaxy not
zelda for the Nintendo DS and not Mario
Kart it's this game Wii Fit
Mario's anole no concept polka dot
bikini fennekin gotten a super net
machine no City no Kissimmee today
quanto econo a kite Inga can it be
mocking by the way actually really love
we met look at their birth rate or
whatever that is 200 pound point Jon's
been demonstrating an aerobic San Jose
who called said you did not develop
Amazon large by playing we've income
come to edit the ideas for this one too
more of a game like feel to it so that
you can actually enjoy shreddy got stuff
cool sorry bro
my man Reggie my body is ready I thought
he got the meme king Reggie
mm-hmm job don't think that's high okay
Reggie please stand on the Wii Balance
Board cool he was hoping for a second as
quickly 15 o any one oh my gosh Reggie
i'ma do my money no oh it took a few
tricks to the face no joke a couple of
years L some of the best times you can
have now supposed to drink beer and get
on Wii Fit we got to bounce out the
calories Oh shucks anyone be right Oh
beautiful memories haha alright Jerry
what would you say the Metacritic score
for Wii Fit was 75 35 button I'm
detecting a pattering it's safe it's 100
point scale so you know yeah sure and
but there are a lot of websites that do
like the 5 scale that gets translated 10
point scales yeah all right we got 75
sir what is your guess 82-75 tubes are
really high for the Wii Fit I think yeah
it was revolutionary yeah everybody
loved the Wii Fit conduct of its time
did you see that guys have much stupider
than Reggie she did it I agree Reggie
goes the world follows and then Elyse
the most fit member of fun house let's
say where did you land on Wii Fit ahh it
was 75 and 80 - right that's correct
Lucy 86 oh hey high but I like that I
don't I don't know I thought you guys
had pretty great like the gamble 25 80
to 86 let's see the score Oh 75 75
when's it Jerry congratulations let me
dig you up something I always like when
people go I think it was really good and
goes ok it's still green there you are
sir there you can take this - who here
had a Wii Fit who here still uses their
Wii Fit
oh oh oh my God where you came
No he gets it thank you guys thank you
for joining us a saving on batteries
gosh we are having a good time aren't we
we're learning and loving remembering
perhaps detecting annuity of a
cautionary tale in some of these but
perhaps no I don't know we learning
lessons on the stage yes you are you
just have to say that then people start
assuming there's more that's true
there's more thought behind what you're
doing than just giving out shirts no no
I sure have but speaking of who wants to
win some shirts so let me get out here
or other stuff man everybody this is so
weird have people shouting my name
excuse me excuse me hmm
I like those glasses Lawrence loves
going in Sol sorry I saw you before he
loves it he does this even when he
doesn't have a microphone on yeah I just
want to run a various people hey wait I
mean essentially what are you mine's the
man of the people
yeah there you go sucky here interest oh
I'm sorry
when Lawrence eventually becomes
dictator of this world he'll be kind and
just so make sure you're nice to
Lawrence cuz yeah he will rule you and
he'll remember if you betrayed him oh
absolutely
you've never met a man more petty more
vindictive than me
hey welcome all right what is your name
sir
Shane Shane nice to meet you in you
Alison Alison
Shane Alison thank you guys for joining
us today let's take a look at the next E
Street clip
[Music]
Arkadia
[Music]
this actually caused a bit of a stir
because this wasn't gameplay but it
represented itself and such yep this was
when they liked the ps3
just getting announced but two years
later they did an actual gameplay demo
pretty exactly this kind of bang on yeah
fake gameplay d3 is not unusual it does
the things that they'd be unlike vision
shows where the gun moves around yeah
that's why the the Metro trailer has
some of that going on and I was like
wait I was feeling the Psalter
Oh
this is a future video game it truly is
a kill zone - nice shop I didn't play
the skin again I remembered having more
cursing superfluous cursing than any
game ever made like you or the game I
mean it was it was hard as well Killzone
2 the debut shooter for PlayStation 3 I
guess no resistance probably whatever
who cares what do you think the
Metacritic score for Killzone 2 I know
nothing about this game uh has three so
eighty eighty safe guess it's it guesses
well we have any 575 oh man okay
people are now people are settling in
always if that 75 that's the zone way
maybe that's that's unattended
commentary on reviews culture planned it
all no I ain't Bruce oh yeah would you
say ah I need this why do I keep doing
yeah now Killzone oh I really want to
get this one right but I'm not going to
I'm gonna say 70 okay oh my god
yeah so 80 75 70 okay let's see what the
score fer Killzone to us oh my god
really people hungry game the perfect
game it was it was it was a core shooter
on ps3 and people kind of needed that
game at the time so it got rated very
high wow I mean it wasn't bad you're
remembering the controversy
maybe yeah yeah Killzone 3 I don't think
reviewed as well yeah I think you're
right it's called kill zone how can it
not that's everything you want the video
that's true it's gotta be 91 or higher
killing swears
alright uh well as in tradition everyone
gets a prize no matter how poorly they
did well he wins yeah good yeah as such
I'm gonna say you get a choice would you
like a you know get it alcoholic
beverage my favorite all right well okay
fair enough
um I've only got a large I don't know
that works okay and then you know you
want to give her a troll shirt huh come
on everybody wants the troll shirt oh
sure that's true not troll shirt huh
careful he might crab walk on you oh
yeah the end that well thank you guys
for playing thank you and thanks again
[Applause]
thank you gosh we sure are learning a
lot about e3 and games journalism are we
we are everything's basically around 80
or 90 you keep saying that or how good
or bad learning people otherwise then
you don't think I'm smart for here right
maybe you're right
yes see cotton all right so it's a troll
yeah classic troll round six
who wants some stop please what up man
oh you have a stairs are on this side
let me oh man I want to get someone from
the back way back there yes you though
guys just stick your leading wildly get
up here you might have to worm your way
through the crowd will heard that free
stuff was on the wings so they're
gathering simply are many stuff this
game is not about very stuff right roll
shirts about learning thank you Bruce
and video games it's about a calm and
respectful discussion of even waiting
for like a really like like I'm trying
to here's what it would be
hey hop in here hello what is your name
Devon Devon nice to meet you Devon and
sir what is your name Logan Logan hey
you guys sound like x-men Oh Devon and
Logan yeah Wow I should team up coolest
and like fight crime maybe they already
do oh I'm sorry if I just put your life
in jeopardy
well whatever let's watch more e3 stuff
huh
oh here we go this is a good one
there's a good one to get you folks
ready to finally be a joke I wanted this
so bad
everyone to it look you know that you're
eating lunch you're the Jedi now Bruce
all the goofy I like how he's getting
shot several times like in the city
[Music]
he's lifting it up oh he dropped it oh
no we get to the first time wow he's
proud
that's how they fight too they go like
this the first thing is Jedi learned to
plant his feet wet your feet never move
them so some battle on
ready looks here
I think they were implying would you
like to be two Jedi fight never made it
us yeah what point do you murder a bunch
of Padawans yeah I think that's airing
the dancing around like meeting up the
card street fighter go to your destiny
Oh
exactly it's exactly how it looks in the
movies I would never want to make anyone
who worked on that game feel bad
hahahaha but it did not really work out
so that was a bit of a hint what do you
think the Metacritic score ended up you
I'm gonna say 70 70 all right and how
about you 38 38 now that's a spread
eight not a prett so we got a 70 a 38
and Star Wars from a number one star
with fan Bruce Green I'm gonna split
this the middle say 50 okay it was 70 50
38 want to make sure got the numbers
right
17:53 all right let's see what the score
ended up being 50 hey man 58 you were so
close 38 nevermind he said 38 1538 and
she said was that was that give that
MIDI then I mean central won yes
okay yeah it ended up having like Han
Solo dancing with strippers in the
Carbonite hey you have a game prototype
it seems to work and it just doesn't
know what you gonna do dance uh all
right well that means we have a winner
the numbers are falling completely out
of my head so I'm sorry i won Bruce
you're sly that's true so now you get to
pick as my prize I want them to not get
either prize oh that's harsh just here
take a shirt all I have left is adult
beverage containers I don't know if
that's a Mac user you have a thinking I
don't see anything you want yeah maybe
you got any hats in there you can have a
shirt with my face on it
there you go huh that's all I'm in
addition you can't get that anymore it's
like all right hold on right check this
material yeah open right up ratchet a
little bit yeah I can wear that yep that
is a shirt right did you think we were
gonna use you as like a coke meal or
something yeah what did ya worry I don't
know I don't know how I do
well thank you thank you very much for
coming up oh yeah thank you for walking
down memory Road with us we're totally
gonna see him selling that shirt outside
the Convention Center why didn't Christ
know that's already happened actually
one of my favorite pastimes is finding
merged with either my face or my
likeness on it in a Goodwill store given
let the toilet talk if you have to do it
yourself just print one up
to them then go back in the store week
later tell me I'd enjoy your life but
that's a big prize I know all right who
wants to win the next round
all right I was saving that till the end
huh
see we'll see I like that I'll I got
dime back you sir yes yes you come in he
was just going somewhere else
you look like it was a walk it leads up
here now or it's crab damn you drunk
walking by trying to play Mario haha
I like the hops sir yes please
I eventually want Peter to start like
fighting each other for my attention
Dobie Dobie don't actually do that never
once we're civilized people we don't hit
hello maybe some awkward petting no
permission first before you pet somebody
on where I'm going with this let's see
the next clip
oh wait I know you guys I'm sorry no
uh-uh all falling apart right now sir
what is your name
Luc Luc nice to meet you in you Jeremy
Jeremy
Luc and Jeremy thank you guys let's
travel three threes history I'm pleased
to announce wonderbook book of spells
Oh is the first time in the title how
nice you look wonderful welcome sell how
I don't know it wonderful yes that's
what I can take a book why didn't see
the book of spells is no ordinary book
um in fact it had all bells kinda cool
those stories come to life in a way
never seen this they're cool so the
dragons are scary you got all kind of
things the idea super going I wish it
was harder to paint off all that so take
that a game good as new
[Music]
that's pretty simple it's as ìshe now
you're ready
the gesture diagram from the page to
cast the fire might draw reflection why
not shame yeah why did you cheat that
you never look at the book though when
it's just a bunch of people I'm Sayla
someone yeah yeah yeah
are you care how many you do pull the
box or luck huh she's having a great
time majesty long pour with it
alright before you get on stage the one
thing you need to do is just smile look
like you're having fun
should oh hey there's great which is
again subtle commentary learning time
please be grateful there are no
industry-wide gimmicks that are sort of
percolating their way at every
conference just games this week games B
are a little bit but whatever all right
what would you guess the Metacritic
score for wonder book book of spells was
2.5 2.5 that's very low point five out
of a hundred oh yeah do you know what
that means you mean that's like 25 or a
two point five will lock him in a two
point five well then again they have a
book so poop okay gets drowsy so maybe
two one five all right two point five
two point five by five all right real
another what would you say anything
higher than that we will probably win
yeah it's um that's a PS Move game
that's like go forty three forty forty
may all come have Olivia almost hit 45
and he was like nope I think I myself
some wiggle room two point five forty
three and the magical ever in the office
Elise what about book of spells I don't
even remember this game coming out oh
man did it did it actually release yes
okay no thing no 5858 okay so it's 2.5
43 and 58 let me write so I remember
this time now I hope it is let's see
what the score is and hopefully somebody
else remembrance what the numbers were
what Co way not 172 y'all are some jaded
jaded people shame on you for not
thinking wonder book book of spells the
other white its genre is miscellaneous
general general how dare you maybe maybe
we learned something we learned
something here about e3 in video games
that not all gimmicks are bad just the
17 that's it kind of yeah that's like
middling yeah mediocre yeah you got to
clean up the book it's cool alright well
let's get you some free stuff I remember
he won it was at least right I did win
yeah the job Elise are any of you enjoy
yours of adult beverages
that's all I got now I think you're
getting that Volturi shirt or tank top
actually you hear I can give you the cup
you can require out of that the chick
water only water oh no you don't think
I'll know you know Lauren sir other
beverages besides adult beverages and
water I know I know but okay why would I
get you a flask oh they're just gonna
drink coke out of it water can be an
adult beverage if you add vodka I've
done that before takes the bite away let
helps you really knock about anything
bite of water away No
whatever thank you guys for yeah thank
you guys thank you that water's hard you
got a temperate [ __ ] flashing image of
Dragon Balls fighters the fine isn't
room where is it
all right I've only got two rounds to go
we can't give it unless they win one and
I got a one-way ticket into meme town
and if you took win and you can't be
gentlemen pointing at you oh good point
that's a good point that's valid come on
thank you sir and what else we got uh
you I like your smile of course any time
all right
Oh sir what is your name Shane Shane
nice to meet you aunt is that our Santa
Fe Hannah Anna sorry about that
if you guys win you'll earn the
quintessential gamer shirt Wow it's not
the grand prize but it's close you got a
yeah you got to
my next one is a pretty deep cut pretty
deep meme
so let's travel back in time to e3 here
to demonstrate the game for us is Bill
rich the executive producer of genji -
great thanks for Genji - is an action
game which is based on Japanese history
I mean based on history VPR's the stages
of the game will also be based on famous
battles which took actually took place
in ancient Japan and stages
Wow I get back work there will be a
massive sea battle sequences which can
only be made possible with the power of
the PlayStation 3 oh just like it's your
doing
enemy crab giant enemy crab what I'll do
is use Benkei yeah - look look we have
this cool samurai now this what a crab
out there
in fact they wanted crabs into Honor no
Genji already did it yeah yeah you ate
oh here comes oh there babe soil ago
respectfulness these are actual things
that happen one man held the telephone
pole and bought a giant revelation of
Okinawa oh it is good I'm coming a new
attack its weak point format damage no
but you'll be able to enjoy sure full
version at our e3 booths bill thank you
very much for thank you I'll see them to
show you originally put this controller
I'll hang it okay I got me he walked off
the stage I said I did a great job right
now oh man he did a great job I mean he
did with what he had yes and I'm sure
positive in fact that the reviews will
reflect that so what would you say the
Metacritic store for Kenji days of the
blade is did you sign straight 50 okay
how about you uh 60 50 taxi all right
no out of all of us James I think you're
the Japanese expert and gamer I thank
you adi got to-- I don't need your only
you're only proving me correct and I
like that so uh based on your knowledge
of Japanese history and elaborating a
game that Sullivan had from what I seen
there absolute accuracy I'm gonna shoot
the moon Lawrence I'm gonna go 100 oh oh
nothing but perfect score fix course
explore for Gangi days is it kept if it
kept going from what I saw in that demo
that's gonna be the perfect game they
already have all the basics yeah crabs
beaches Jam memorize Chum yeah alright
let's see the final score for Kenji days
of the blade 0:05 is that Hanna I was no
we were all wrong wait y'all went over
he said 50 oh you said 50 all right
all then that make bread juicer that
makes you the clay Wow okay
quintessential gamer but it's okay you
get this sweet James angel runner-up
prize all right thank you guys thank you
for playing oh nice meeting you and
thank you Japan for your rich and cult
colorful history all right guys we're
down to the last one
oh this last one wasn't a good one too
this is it yeah this is actually this is
actually something you want to win I
don't think it's on sale yet right not
on sales on sale yeah the purple shirt
in the back
yeah coveted eSports funhouse shirt
sorry I'm sure your friends will know
you're a loser immediately uh on that's
been you look you look pretty happy
thank you for watching I like happy
people at e3 that's what it's about it's
easy to scoff at everything no we're
here to celebrate games and the fact
that they're all great every last one oh
thanks for watching man I thought you
were Adam at first
all right sorry what's your name Edgar
Edgar nice to meet you and you are
shucks arshad are shocked are shocked
okay our son or Shaq okay our chakras I
have so many names Beelzebub
he has many faces he appears at night in
parking lots across the world all right
let's see the final III memory this
one's gonna cut a little deep
hahaha tiny little e my lucky I do good
god bless you I do
I love the movie there I love Sean MERS
the biggest will be delightful
science-fiction gang
I guess inspired by he does they share
their universe whether keep there he
does her about that soon Heinlein eyes
lost clock there was a plant he was
crying he was trying a happy today right
pursuing right now he's not trying
somewhere I like what infinite and it's
one that everyone can share I want to
finish with just a tiny taste of what
your own unique journey into infinity
might look like
[Applause]
doesn't happen
[Music]
like big ships sometimes you know what
universe is infinite maybe it was
someplace I never got to I'll finally
played it probably nine hours yeah yeah
yeah oh man sky all right
the most recent game to get
unfortunately flamed alive at e3 or
because of e3 why'd you say the
Metacritic score of that ended up being
I'll give it a high 90 high 90 high you
have to pick a number 90 99 D high 90
okay a 90 90 excellent guess probably
going to win how about you sir
well it had pretty good height but then
it went down so I'm gonna say 55 55 Wow
it's a safe guess off to the 90 there
that's a hefty hefty spread there yeah
man I'm trying to decide which one of
you loves no man's sky the most Hey
Bruce please okay okay do you ever
actually played you played it on the
plane for like two hours yeah yeah hey
what would you what would your
Metacritic guess for no man's sky V ah
it's got to be like a 71 okay I'm gonna
say 71 all right it's a good spread bets
all around the roulette table well let's
see what was a Metacritic score for no
man's sky Oh a perfect guest from Bruce
yeah I did not see the answers
previously thank you very much sir
William Ayers 'ya exclusive merch wow
this is nice that user score four point
five yeah people I thought about having
to be a little I mean so it went back
and forth right it looks good on you
it's gonna look great on you when your
eSport thing ready hero for eSports
enthusiasts everywhere we all he sports
now there you go all right well thank
you all right well thank you guys for
joining you can wear that when you watch
overwatch thank you
oh yeah no problem game thank you thank
you guys thank you thanks like you know
I guess we have a couple more stuff yeah
but the other few more things if you
want free stuff hang around no I'm gonna
give it all away now so you got a lot
way monsters realize how bad that would
make us look when he crashed this is
that we get booked again so uh that'll
do it for the medic
metacritic combat I didn't really come
up with a name for it well
Machop that later what's the name anyway
thanks everybody for playing and we're
going to talk about summary three stuff
right now
okay I believe the UH the idea is now
going to discuss the demos and stuff
that we liked and then ones that we
didn't and give explanations y-yeah uh
know who's who's got powerful thoughts
about them what's to start
he's got powerful thoughts Elise Jane I
mean I don't but I can talk what we're
here for right uh should we start with
the good ready we should rather like a
positivity sandwich right well I'll give
you my two goods right one bad and then
one bad to good and to right sure oh
yeah I got you okay yeah okay so um game
of show Dragonball Fighters Z this game
of show again what still kind of played
it yet but Mother of God how perfect is
that look really good
it can't sit basically marble it's yeah
okay yeah marble Budokai 3 huh he's
still talking now he's doing anyway so I
like the game um the only question is
does anyone have a beat on what the
actual title is Dragonball Fighters no I
think it's Rena bolts Dragon Ball by Big
Z what is it Ryder also Big Z does
anybody know I get balls the fighter
officials a Dragonball Fighters II
Dragonball Fighters II okay okay now I
know I think so
Dragonball Fighters be gosh and this
Xbox one it in hands but like wait I
don't know that it looks it's perfect it
looks so good at least I always love the
Budokai series and then it kind of
started getting away from that when it
went into like third-person camera it
was God's people power they were trying
to do because it was like a big fight
across the world and the level but the
level was just rocks that you just
smashed through anyway and so it didn't
mean as much that you could just press
up and like circle or up and be and then
you fire Kamehameha like that wasn't as
cool as trying to execute some
so I'm really very very excited for this
game very very very I need to admit it
but now that I'm watching it on a proper
monitor not our little tiny little
governor it is beautiful in this in how
manic and frantic be like combat is does
look pretty cool in it but from what
I've watched I've been watching some
gameplay of it too like it's pretty it's
pretty seems pretty straightforward like
it's just quarter-circle forward and two
punches to do super attacks and then
there's like a light heavy light medium
heavy system and then a special attack
system and everything like that and then
the you can bring in tag in people but
they're just on a cool-down so you can
do any time you want to you can bring
them in and stuff so I'm really excited
it looks like it it's coming from like
the guilty gear BlazBlue guys right I
think it's our system yeah so like they
have very complex fighting games yeah
this looks like it's kind of
intermediate like so it's not gonna
scare off people that don't play all the
time who are you gonna main t- main I
have a guest I mean probably Vegeta but
why would you go piccolo take a logic
will snow here Brad guy Vegeta piccolo
doesn't transform mcquoddy de piccolo
doesn't transform and I saw that you if
you're playing as Goku he's super saying
too but there's a move you can do where
he goes Super Saiyan 3 and if you could
transform that's like that's a deal
breaker
piccolo can't transform he's just like
I'm more powerful as gonna blow on your
birthday cake not anymore
I've already had piccolo my bro yeah
that's the I did actually I pick a lot
of my birthday cake can we play three on
three so three funhouse versus three
funhouse or I don't think it's only you
you could theoretically play where each
person picks someone and when I die you
come in as Vegeta cuz I wanted you to
carry me I guess don't carry you I just
never let it get to the point where you
have to fight okay great perfect perfect
and I'm gonna chill for a second I think
that game's gonna look awesome in higher
than 1080p it's like all the like speed
lines and stuff and just the sparks and
stuff falling off temple charging absol
I think that could be a real visual
showcase it's gonna look better than the
cartoon ever did yeah which is pretty
cool yeah I've been watching super maybe
that's it like if it's pretty incredible
I don't need to
ah man she's being honest yeah I've
heard the Dragon Ball would have fluffed
content and nobody needs to
and you can destroy the levels so like
you can deflect little they have little
fireballs that they can do and when you
deflect them they fly off into the back
of the stage
oh cool and they like blow up stuff and
then if you end with like a level 3
super it'll like blow up the earth
basically and so then the next round
you're basically in like a lava pit like
when when Goku fought Frieza and stuff
like that and it just looks awesome
I just put my finger on it this is kind
of like scratching Yost Rose wrath pitch
cuz they'll never be another one of
those but this is kind of close no one
played that yeah yeah so James what is
your next positive game of show next
positive game of the show I'm gonna go
to the last night okay that looks really
cool really does I don't know a thing
about it but it looks cool it the
soundtrack I mean I think you're you you
you're really excited about that too
that's gonna be one of my games so we
may yeah I'll be back onto that yeah
yeah yeah it's like 2.5 D Blade Runner
is kind of the way everybody's
describing it and I think that makes the
most sense and I think the way that it
in Corpse incorporates moving from like
pixel art to 2.5 D is really really cool
yeah what's it's cool because you see
sometimes there's like these movements
oh yeah look it's so good guys I'm gonna
be amazing too I was like oh sorry I
obviously I'm really tired of like 8-bit
games a really tired side-scrolling and
this is this is exactly the change that
I needed to get me into it well
sometimes there's like these stylistic
movements in games so like trying to
think of the name of it it was like
sword and sword and Sworcery sword and
sorcery right like it was like tall leg
man with like large thigh gap and stuff
like that and then they had the rosea
oxen-free looks very similar to that and
I always like when they do something new
with the style of a game but then when
that becomes the style like cel-shading
some game dissociating first joke whoa
and then everything does it makes it
less impressive this brought it back
around again in at least a little that
we saw there it like brings it back
around you're oh my god it looks so good
I'll go first like artistic style over
graphical fidelity any day so for me
like this is kind of the best of both
worlds because
it does look like it's sort of pushing
graphics in terms of like how good it
looks by the styles there - uh it's all
like it but I mean it's like I'm making
this trailer oh my gosh yeah it looks so
bad ground I wish I knew a little bit
more about how it played the trailer
kind of into camp but it like you and I
thought it was a flashback yeah they
were doing flat quick look but um pick
up items use them on thing it does seem
more like a point-and-click but man just
the idea of exploring that world and if
we're not gonna get a Blade Runner game
like I already was one I was a big fun
nobody played a Mad Max game and I okay
and of the I'm glad that shadow wars
coming out right because they were like
tie-ins to movie franchises but you
didn't really need them it just kind of
gave you the vibe of it you I wish we
had one of those for the new Blade
Runner movie but it looks like this is
this gonna be fill that be closed in
cyberpunk yeah I'm out sometime sometime
whatever yeah I still haven't seen
anything from that oh there's nothing a
woman on her knees that's the one
getting shot at certainly they got
hacked recently CD Projekt had to put
out a statement saying like we're not
gonna pay this so please yeah maybe
don't look at it but we won't blame me
if you do yeah yeah ah we'll see okay
James so now for the thing everyone
loves from e3 commentators and
journalists negativity yeah what is a
the game you hated and why um Detroit is
Detroit Oh is gonna be this is gonna be
my hated game I forgot they announced
that Oh cuz I watched it like that's the
difference this is the game like if
robots could feel I'm sure we're really
gonna get a lot of introspection on the
game where occasionally I hit a to
continue the story oh this is the
opposite side of it
so you show me a game like Dragon Ball Z
fighters and you show me a game like the
last night and I'm thinking about how
beautiful they are
there's a lot of technical aspects of
that but then this is just this is just
like a wanking motion for graphics to me
like I feel really good for the the
performance capture artists who are
doing this and like portraying the roles
but man I don't think that the game is
going to be any different than what
we're watching here if the the studio's
resume has anything to indicate they're
only getting further and further away
from making video games and
closer and closer to just making movies
where occasionally you had acts you
technically you don't like David cage
games typically right not real why play
them play everything alone I play them
and then I but and the weird thing is
what was it heavy rain yeah wait all of
heavy rain and I was like I like the
points where they let me play the game
like doing detective work and stuff like
that I was like so hopefully the next
game he makes will have more of that and
less of the other stuff where you're
just just pressing X while you're
running around a corner running into
jobs and then we played beyond 2 souls
and then I didn't even finish it because
a the story sucked and then and B it was
note it had none of the detective cool
interesting stuff it was literally the
only freedom you had was walk from this
area to the next area
you know uncharted does that to where
there's a cutscene and it goes for some
reason you have to control Drake while
he's walking through a prison just so
that way you can get to another cutscene
but then the idea is that then you're
going to break out of the pair then
there's a lovely the game beyond two
souls never had that oh there's a great
moment in the in the game where B Ellen
Page decides to go and go to a bar
against her better judgment she goes to
a bar and she's hanging out there and
some guy comes up to her and goes like
hey you want to play some pool with me
and he's real seems real sketchy you're
given options to either say like oh yeah
that's all go do something wild and act
out of behavior or whatever no or you
can say no I'm cool I'm meeting someone
no thank you
I said no I said no I'm okay I'll meet
someone else and they're like you sure
and then she goes okay I'll play and
like why did I why did you give me the
option to pick if there's join me
there's one resolution who's gonna say
no to a pool minigame they worked so
hard on I understand I reckon I just I
seriously have my doubts that this will
be a game I I'm hoping it flips our
expectations maybe we think we've come
to expect from David cage
maybe all right back to positivity back
specific what's your what's your third
liking choice
Super Mario Odyssey yeah it looks
amazing and it's got a it's got an
amazing theme song yep that stuff's
gonna earworm me pretty hard over the
coming I I got to play it I got to play
it
very briefly and it was awesome and like
I was saying to you before we started
anytime a new Mario game comes out the
first thing I do is try and triple jump
because playing Super Mario 64 as a kid
that was like like come on get a triple
jump timing please please um and it was
so slight immediately just was jumping
in and doing everything perfectly there
was because it's e3 there's someone
they're there to help you and you just
almost don't need it cuz it just feels
exactly like Mario okay and and even
just not like I saw Bullet Bill and I
just went and threw my hat at him and
then I was the Bullet Bill and doing
everything I I'll of all the Mario games
the galaxy series is great but something
about it was lost for me because it felt
like you were just going it's just like
they're like a thousand worlds and
you're gonna visit all of them I always
liked the idea of having less worlds but
then growing like a really intimate
connection with them so like you know
super dog city and stuff like that and
there was a desert world that I went to
I feel like you're going to be going
back to them again and again in
exploring new corners of them as opposed
to galaxies which was kind of like just
progressing down like you know one one
one two one three
I watched Elise go up the side of the
building just like this like no one told
her they did she just like intuitively
was like boom what is this and beat you
goes up to the top so it looks like in
graphically again amazing it just looks
stunning just I agree with all of those
things so I was if you guys if you guys
are curious a tree house actually has
like two 20-minute demos of both of both
the levels they have at e3 so if maybe
the lines too long you don't get a
chance to play it that is a pretty good
job walking you through everything
that's here it's actually pretty cool
thing I wish every developer would do
that yeah like here's our e3 demo we're
gonna do a hosted game play yeah right
hey man now see the Assassin's Creed
point this is where Mario does
Assassin's Creed oh yeah better get down
there that's that's the other cool
aspect too so uh other Mario games
sunshine and 64 when you got a shiner
you got a star it closed you out of the
level yeah so was that weird aspect of
well I found this one but that's right
near the entrance yeah I should go find
another one that's harder to get to yeah
and the moons in this game you pick them
up and keep going so there's that never
that aspect
of making you plan the most efficient
ways that you just see a thing you go to
it get it and then people it seems like
there's still the mission Oh like you
get into a level and there's a mission
and there and then that's like one of
the moons but then along the way if
you're like accidentally stumble across
another moon it's not a big deal to go
grab it you know so like the one I was
on was like just get to the top of this
tower and whatever you find along the
way that's what it's gonna be the one
Elise was doing in Superdog city it was
like oh we need a band to play for the
festival yeah there's there's a guy
playing trumpet and it's like can you
find all the members of the band so like
that's like the over over mission okay
and then and then everything else you
can do just kind of on the fly and
explore but man the world is so big you
vibrate love it it looks great Wow yeah
alright Engler all not disappoint final
final positive game for e3 what's your
last pick uh Wolfenstein yeah that's
good stuff
yeah thank you this looks like it's just
gonna be like I love the first one
because it was just like a rollercoaster
first-person shooter there's very few
points or it was like I gotta hide or I
gotta follow anyone else in the battle
it was like you go blaskowitz shoot
everything destroy everything have a
great time doing it so I actually I
never got to play Doom I haven't played
it yet that's my bad I take that on me
that's my fault
um but I love first-person shooters that
step in and just say like just blow blow
your way through everything you know so
I'm very excited for uh for Wolfenstein
- yeah man I am - new order was so so
good
an old blood was like good in a
different way it was more of a tomb I'm
just
BG blaskowitz their version of him it's
such an amazing character and that he's
just kind of a one-dimensional Nazi
genocide of maniac yeah well he's like
he's like got two shotguns he's going
nuts and he's like reciting poetry to
himself in his own head yeah that stuff
so awesome and the fact that like there
was some allusion to the fact that Anya
in the first game on a camera name but
it she hated nazi so much that she loved
him just because he murdered Nazis so I
don't know there's just so many we look
for so humanity can find a common bond
and him hating Nazis it's just such a
safe target voltage and her neo-nazi
yeah yeah yeah yeah there she is and I
swear I could be wrong about this but at
the end of the trailer when that dude
drops acid I'm pretty
that's one of the two dudes you can save
a new order oh I think you're right so I
think citing that you don't save the
captain guys yes instead
oh no I see my Knapton I don't remember
anyway
cool stuff I'm just glad to these
Bethesda k-- is willing to publish these
kinds of games she's back yeah I guess a
nice ticket stitched together not fair I
killed her
that's been that gnarly technology
though you can't knock it alright they
may be horrific
but they really push the envelope
apparently technology very advanced oh
you got big robot dogs we don't have
those now that's kind of thing for
everybody that uh for everybody that
maybe it's feeling sore about halflife3
just never happening at this point I'm
not saying it's the same but this is the
cut this is that kind of game it is the
equivalent and if man if you looked
half-life do yourself a favor and play
play to order for sure alright at least
I want to hear what you have to pick uh
so for me I was incredibly excited when
Ori and the blind forest 2 was announced
yeah um it was one of my favorite games
of 2015 and it was a little uh it was a
it was a big announcement
it had leaked beforehand some
screenshots and the title will the wisps
had a leak so I always feel really I'm
excited for me when I see those things
because I get hyped but then I always
feel a little bit bummed for the
developers who worked so hard and we're
waiting for that big chance to reveal
their game but we only kind of saw a
little bit of a teaser not really a full
trailer or gameplay necessarily it's
really beautiful and if you played the
first story
you kind of know the story about the
owls
what kind of what happens there so what
they how they like got okay with this
one like right away I was like oh oh no
it's like it's it's back into that
emotional world I thought it was one of
the like best new games and the
resurgence of those very Metroidvania as
platformers and I love collecting the
orbs I know who doesn't you guys do I
missed some orbs and Ori and it drove me
drove me insane I can't go back to the
tree yes you go back
hoping there's a way that this game
finds to do something newer compared to
the first one but then I'm also just
happy to have more of the same I never
played the DLC so now I'm also like
reinvigorated to go back and do that and
I I do have to say that Ori the way it
did those like fast music levels that
were a very rayman legends' esque i
would definitely want more of that
so hopefully we get that i think you're
probably excited for worried I'm very
excited I feel like Ori had a certain
challenge to it that was gratifying so
like you would die a lot playing that
game over and over and over again but it
was optimized so that way you would die
and then immediately respawn in a closed
checkpoint so those those fast challenge
levels were so enjoyable to play because
it wasn't like not trying to be negative
on dark souls but it wasn't like Dark
Souls where there's a challenging
section if you lose that challenging
section you get thrown back to
who-knows-where
with less than you had before it's like
like you're just going again try it
again try it again now and then you're
learning a little bit and so then it's
super gratifying it at the end it feels
like you performed like some sort of
magical dance sequence because it's
never just hit X to continue its do the
blast move and then that will deflect
you here and then bounce up the walls
and things close behind you there's the
fire and there's an owl and and the way
you're unlocking skills also to keep the
game feeling fresh as you're playing it
I was great I'm excited to see how they
build on the soundtrack yeah that
soundtrack Garret poker Gareth Coker I
think did the soundtrack for the first
one I still listen to it all the time
yeah ready alright what's your what's
your next pick um like to be honest
Mario Odyssey and the last night were
two of my other picks um but then I got
it because I also really liked I'm
excited to try the demo for The Artful
escape
that's Annapurna interactive who did
what remains of Edith Finch are
publishing that game and it is the same
I think it's a music game I think it
might be a rhythm game we talked about
this that it had legs like it here it
does guys have a demo and I'm hoping to
get to it today
can i yeah we'll see here too but like
these I'll wheeling out on like a
spaceship as its flying around yeah real
cool I'll be interested to see how much
like music and rhythm plays a part I
just have a lot of faith in this
publisher to keep this this in ashen
we're two of the games they showed off
that looked really cool
BIA has a really state fast-paced
platforming vibe I just I'm glad that
we're at a point kind of with III like
talking about e3 where games like this
get to have a showcase
yeah even Ori like it leaked but you
were still excited to see it at a - such
a large stage you know presented for all
these people like it feels like not too
long ago would be like like here's sonic
and then that's it like you're like
here's the new Mario game and that's it
or here's the hardware and that's it you
know a lot of first-person shooters in
sport yeah but something like this some
indie indie darling like this seems like
really cool that's show up I'm also just
like really I'm easily entranced by like
a lot of conceptual art and logos so
like if you show me something like this
I'm like like it like cuphead no I'm
totally not a boss rush person but just
like all that that cuphead 1930s Disney
it looks it looks amazing yeah it really
does um so like this just just seeing
the visuals I'm like okay I'm definitely
interested um time to it's time to talk
some mess what do you hate Elyse I want
to know what you hate cuz your face of
it here came out too close to offend
your Sensibility I thought this a3 was
actually pretty safe in a lot of ways so
there wasn't a game that can't like it
there wasn't a book of spells no high
score 70% on Mac it's pretty good I I
think there are just more so games that
I'm sort of indifferent to um so like
and don't boo me you guys are gonna boo
boo Freddy get your booze read like
crackdown 3 not a bad looking game but
I'm sort of indifferent to it because
I'm not not crackdown fan nobody's
booing very polite audio I'm doing
and I also really let me hear guys are
kind of kind of mild on crackdown 3 a
lot of nodding okay that guy's excited
all right sex wing guys I'm also like a
big Terry Crews fan so I was I would
love if I got Terry Crews in a game that
I was like excited for but that being
said this game looks fun and I think
we'll probably have fun playing on the
channel rip into it and equal no one
wanted I mean yeah nobody crackdown oh
and like just come times sports games
I'm just a little bit jamming FIFA
updates and stuff I'm a little
indifferent to so more of an
indifference other than it just seems
that so this got announced last year era
games or something and I I don't know I
guess I expected some kind of tech demo
when one building falls into another
building with me and they didn't show
that yeah I mean it was weird that's
that's their chance to sort of wow
people with the escalation factor of
okay Rana knew we're on a new generation
we got the 1x coming out yep the 1x is
all about horsepower so let's so show
something that really blows people's
minds I didn't do things falling over
yeah oh yeah do it
I mean I'm sure it's gonna be in the
game that's like the gameplay is
knocking stuff over oh yeah all right
Bruce okay yeah so I'll go quick cuz I
know we've been talking a long time
Beyond Good and Evil 2 yeah is
absolutely yeah know what I mean I was
gonna say I'm surprised at least take it
yeah why didn't you unlike the stream um
well be like a strange yeah alright life
is strange that's right yeah very good
no that's fine these are my guesses for
you but being able to I think uh it's in
a this magical time of video game hype
where people remember it very fondly
they remember the first one very fondly
and also we only got this trailer so the
art style and the visuals are just
amazing and when I was watching this I
was like I would like to see this movie
it there well I mean like there really
wasn't a video game in this trailer
which was fine with me
it just got me excited and it's much
like the no man's sky hype where you saw
no man's sky and you're like whoa I
can't believe he did that that wasn't
quite what it was so I try to temper my
expectations on these things that said
that was really exciting to see the
developers get up there and cry because
they were so they were so passionate
about what they've been doing also that
part
right and I was that part when she
bought the desk um but he's me yeah and
and it was just it was exciting to see
that whole team come up and I think
they've probably been sitting on this
for what a year two years they weren't
they weren't able to talk oh yeah they
weren't able to talk about it and they
were finally able to reveal this I mean
like and it and it ended the Ubisoft
press conference they they basically
headlined the Ubisoft press conference
and it's totally worth it it was one of
those games that I I don't know if it'll
ever reach the hype that it has now but
it looks amazing if I'm not mistaken I
might be but I I think that the Last
Guardian was announced and came out
during the time frame like this was
announced Oh happen remember a long time
ago there was the well there was that
test for trade running around and then I
think shortly thereafter UB saw was like
yeah we're working on work and I and now
they didn't say really working on it I
think I think with this I I read equip
that there like a day zero of
development on beyond good naval to so I
think it's just been concept and stuff
like that I think they finally decided
yes we're gonna greenlight this for real
yeah cuz there was like a image on
Facebook or something a year ago that
they should Oh everyone everyone was
like losing their minds
yeah wait there were two traitors no I
so there was the like the quote-unquote
leaked gameplay of Jayde running around
then there was the short teaser of like
a Cajun
sitting on the car with Jayde in the
background this one didn't unless that
old pig man is Paige I don't think any
of the characters were in the trailer
from the other game that's kind of weird
um I know there's been some features and
interviews about the scope of the game
apparently it's trying to be pretty big
which is weird but that's they're
showing what's up yeah in the trailer so
it you know like hopefully we can trust
the trailer a little bit to give us a
somewhat represent like a visual
representation of the game I think it's
okay to trust the art style yes because
and sells games have always been
wonderfully artistic like working and
weird in that cool French way there's
not a whole lot of expression like that
this term Taiwanese so much of Fifth
Element just because it's like yep this
weird French sci-fi intersection I don't
know what it is about it but the music's
there interesting like I mean I just may
be blanking out if I can't think of
other scenarios where there's this
business of this game like beyond get
good knee
obviously did well that people have it
has a legacy and people like it but not
well enough that it became a big
franchise and that's kind of how gaming
works so it's interesting that it was a
relatively smaller thing before and now
it's blasting off and it be similar is
like a lots trip yeah but sure it
doesn't look like they're making a
triple-a site I haven't seen any but
doesn't look like they're making a trip
with Colt they go nuts - yeah looks like
they're trying to make a Psychonauts
that would compete with the Psychonauts
at the time yeah yeah I think to your
point Lawrence what what seems great
about this is it's like a good mix of
sci-fi and humor yeah which like their
movies like you know Fifth Element that
does that well and guardians the galaxy
does that well and it's like a goofy er
and and that that's what is majorly
appealing about this yeah that was the
hype of the first game - yeah yeah a lot
of cool music a lot of just weird
encounters with strange creatures that
are like they start in their end and
you're just like that was just quirky
just a quirky game
all right beats whatever what's next one
will be quick skull and bones yeah I
guess I was the only person in the world
that played Assassin's Creed 4 I loved
the boat so much that I was like I
didn't really need if I could play my
friend in a boat and put my other friend
in another boat against him so then that
way we're all in boats fighting each
other and I that was I don't know I just
really liked that part of SATA Street
for not a huge like assassin fan of
Assassin's Creed I've played that
through only because I had to but it
wasn't like I said again back to my boat
yeah no but the boat was that was always
the the part that I was really excited
about so I'm excited about Skull and
Bones
um it should be fun yeah it should be
fun a bigger boat so so my I was I was
trying to Mull this over because I was
like it's weird that they made a game
out of some that one aspect of a game
that they've already made before yeah
but then I was thinking about for honor
and when firaon reversed announced they
were like it's melee combat I'm like
that seems like less then other games
have except that they got into the nitty
gritty of saying what makes melee combat
interesting how can we make that the
game and make it satisfying so I am
excited to say like okay what they are
they clearly want to figure out
something about
boat battles right that other games have
it done and expand it so that way it's
all game me on paper it made perfect
sense because of all the people I would
talk about Black Flag with everyone
would say that the boat battles and just
being about was their favorite parts of
the game I love it you it you would
always talk about that so it's like they
honed they own in and said how do we
harness this and make a game just about
this and this is clearly what people are
it's resonating with them
dawn one of our editors he said this is
his game of the show - really yeah he's
really sick cuz that was one of his
favorite things about Black Flag as well
well this this for me is I always I've
always said ocean combat it's something
that nobody ever dives into you when it
comes to video games or movies or
whatever that's why I really like the
movie Battleship because right right
because it's mean like it was terrible
it's terrible movie but there were some
really cool scenes where like two boats
for fighting each other and you don't
see that stuff very often so that's why
I was excited about this ah it drifted a
boat um I'll get the negative out of the
way right now so everybody can boo me uh
I thought Mario plus rabbit looks stupid
rabbits mad Mario rabbits my rabbits I
only because I don't like XCOM so I was
just sort of like whatever I kind of
shook that one off everybody said it's
amazing I know I know everybody said
it's amazing to play but I haven't
played it I'm sure I loved it if I
played it look at peach rabbit tattooed
on the small of my back that sound
that's a good idea
uh yeah and I'll only do one more
positive one anthem alright um and
anthem that was an amazing video game
that if that's all in if that's all in
game it looked like it was game played a
minute it did I think it did it's a an
engine or did it's a gameplay it looked
like gameplay it looked like gameplay to
me and this looked like almost a more
polished third-person destiny yeah and
it just it just excited me to see
excited me to see this this is my kind
of this is my kind of man yeah this
Micah it's it is a is a triple-a like
graphically intensive with it within a
kind of a unique art style but also a
realistic art style that's it's the
combination of both I know a lot of
games look like this but this is kind of
stuff that gets me really excited and
then you get to find out like what kind
of rocket cease firing and what kind of
bullets cease firing and what kind of
creatures there are in the world
like here's my concern about anthem
halfa if you can just fly where can you
go cuz anywhere well but it looks like
they're on a pretty hard path you go
anywhere you go underwater like a pretty
hard path if it were me I'm going right
out that a wall right there I'm going
over the edge absolutely like I'm gonna
hit something oh it's so cool that is so
cool well I'm gonna say actually anthem
is the one game that I didn't like and
although I'll tell you I I've been
through this so many times so many times
you guys it looks so good but it's gonna
be a video game you're gonna pick up a
gun some of the numbers are gonna be
read some of them are gonna be green
Lloris these they're gonna add my four
bullets into more real about loot
Lawrence this is video games and then
you shoot him and white numbers pop out
his body and yelling everything got a
head butt but Laurie looks down to see
if your cooldowns up and you throw a
yellow ball and you throw an orange ball
and then you but Lawrence its III I know
man
it's a video game what game do you get
the man who's played everything Rabbids
and Mario that's right rabbits no I I
want it to be good it's just there's
gonna be a moment where it's it's a
video okay it's a game and that's gonna
be the part like that frustrates me what
I don't want to happen what scares me is
games provide the illusion of con you
you can't make a lot of this this is
real expensive really expensive so what
worries me is the the world has such
fidelity that I'm worried it might be a
destiny thing where you're in a bubble
and the bubble looks amazing when you're
in the bubble and they try to keep you
in that bubble doing as much stuff as
they can because it costs so much money
to make that so that's what worries me a
lot that you're gonna see this and it's
gonna be amazing
oh my god it's oh it's so pretty damn it
it's so awesome but there's no way they
can make all of that for an entire world
right we're not at that point are well
are we there no I mean you see they're
gonna say thank you so what's going to
happen is this is going to be that
bubble it's gonna be a really big bubble
everything else and all the DLC is going
to send you underground so that way the
flying is one row anywhere now you're in
tunnels and it's gonna basically be
dungeon crawling kind like that's what
destiny did oh he's gonna shoot missiles
out just like Iron Man oh I also have a
concern too because there's a loot
system in it yeah my guess is that you
there's
be like artillery there's gonna be
railgun and there's gonna be automatic
weaponry and then it just alternates
between those those no bill like you'll
get you'll get some super crazy loot and
then it'll but it'll still just be the
artillery again but it'll do 2.5 times
crit or something like that
all right so I think you're right I but
I'm still excited for it they showed
they showed a lot it definitely looks
like it's gonna be fun I just I got you
know I'm getting through the break-up
I'm finding a new path in my life in the
toy yeah my phone lights up and I'm like
baby I can't do this in again I can't do
it again are you doing this to me you
know it's not good for me break up with
what I mean there every general every
every like looter shooter I mean I feel
like I know once a destiny was bad the
big biggest problem with destinies that
locked you out of content until you
brined it that's what mmo's do but you
pay monthly for that I guess I'm worried
that again since his content is so
expensive they're gonna make you replay
the same thing multiple times to see the
next really expensive thing cuz there it
can't it can't be full of stuff but it
maybe it is maybe it is maybe Bioware
has been just pouring millions and
millions of dollars into this so
environmental artists can make entire
planets that look as amazing as that
they did you're you're definitely gonna
spend a lot of time doing this exact
flight again but it might be fun maybe I
want it to be I just did hurts there's
there's a dagger in my heart and why or
just twisted it a little bit also I I
don't want this to influence it but it
does I got some grievances against
Bioware oh I don't know oh so I bought
and I bought into Dragon Age Origins
hard I bought in a Mass Effect hard I
was like pirates back and they got it
and then Dragon Age 2 was bad and Mass
Effect slid for me at least based on the
games I liked so it's a complicated
relationship okay seeing this is
tweaking me out anyway you can go ahead
you can continue from alright I guess my
positives I just shuffle them around
because I mean we all kind of synced up
last night Mario uh but I thought Metro
was a cool reveal yeah
not gameplay but I liked Metro both
metros quite a bit and the fact that
they're making another one is great I
love like quirky shooters from middle
Europe that's just a weird genre of
thing that's kind of going along and the
fact that they can
really good at math and I'm really
excited to see what they can do with the
1x so I feel like that is kind of the
it's the killzone 2 equivalent it's the
Shadowfall equivalent it's this is the
shooter that's going to blow you away I
guess anthem can be that to potentially
and I guess destiny - yeah yeah this it
looks it just looks amazing but doesn't
let yourself always looked great they've
always said unto me yeah they had a
knack for it I don't know what they did
my plate looks so good uh and then so
this is for I guess my final positive
pick
aside from once you guys picked was a
Spider Man Allawi so I was worried when
I first saw a Spider Man yeah um and uh
cuz I mean you guys played spider-man 3
maybe not but no everyone agreed they
didn't like it and I don't know why but
it had a whole lot of QTEs and at the
time that's what everyone said this is
the thing that's bad so when they do a
new spider-man demo that's full of QTEs
it worried me not because I don't like
I'm fine with QTEs but I think people
keep getting tricked by that stuff and I
don't know I was I was concerned I
haven't seen I haven't seen what I want
to see which is the transition from open
world into a mission out into the open
world again kind of like argh um a
little bit sorry like I can talk about
like arkham combat and then into the
open world and then yeah sort of like
that transition yes they theoretically
showed it during the show sort of
because he takes down all those dudes on
this guy's bird with any trace of the
helicopter and theoretically helicopters
in open world but nothing about that
sequence showed me a failed state yeah
which is a really nerdy way to talk
about it but what happens if you miss
any of those turns there it looks like
there's one point when he's chasing the
helicopter where he misses it does look
like it and he goes to the other side of
the helicopter yeah so I don't know
maybe they I mean maybe this my hope is
that they can push QTEs in a different
direction so it isn't get it and you
lose its get it and now you move to the
third phase of this battle or whatever
it is and so you're going to see a
different chain of events that maybe are
more difficult than if you had hit them
all right the first time so you end up
on the other side of the helicopter you
lose that one now you're on the rotor
now you have to whip the rotor down and
then they take down the helicopter a
different way but I don't know possible
yeah you know what uh Stephanie my
girlfriend was playing parappa the other
day and it's essentially a QTE a really
big one and I realized with paratha if
you fail enough you go you click down
into we're sounding versions of the song
yeah something like that where you have
like a hidden life bar if you Biff
enough cuties then suddenly spider-man's
like banged up or you lose health or
you're in a a different phase I mean
heavy rain tried to do that a little bit
but yeah I I really dig the like it's
essentially like Batman fighting that's
cool they have environmental stuff
there's some shots where he like Yanks a
crane and knock some dudes over he like
drops in front of three dudes and whips
a girder on them that stuff is like very
spider-man and it's very cool that they
represented that in the combat engine uh
but yeah that's I guess kind of like
anthem I haven't seen the thing that
proves to me that it's it's not going to
be like here's a man with a glowing
pillar of light on him hit triangle talk
to him
mission start where you're kind of
locked into an area that's fine if I
didn't if that's what it ends up being
but I guess I have a whole lot of faith
in insomniac I mean Ratchet and Clank
sunset overdrive these guys have made
every amazing open-world 3d action game
basically ever so there's no reason to
not expect the best spider-man game ever
from them which is a you know it's
hyperbole but yeah I just meant I want
it to be good
I think the Arkham thing is probably
pretty good yeah I think the leg like
this is probably the e3 version of
things where they set up the they set up
the pins knowing that they only had to
knock down the first one then it would
just get going but I do think that it's
gonna feel a lot more like Arkham like
that it's like okay there's you're on
this mission and this is where the next
thing is for it and it's gonna move in
and out of that kind of seamlessly but
ultimately I I love how he just
dismantles the big guy so quickly huh
like when I hang in the box there you go
then he just beat his ass yeah I uh I
guess I'm kind of curious about the plot
- you got these dudes with like the
glowy energy hands there's been a couple
of them but uh well see ya but I guess
um I don't wrap it up for me and I think
that'll wrap it up for us
so I was fast we have some stuff to
throw out but thank you guys for joining
us
yeah really pi/8 yeah
oh sure uh who who wants a yeah
no one's gonna raise her hands anyone of
League uh okay I like that
alright well thank you guys for joining
us and things going to throw it back to
the GameSpot demo stage to please stay
tuned thank you